[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance merry Christmas to America
from Robert Muller well it's not big
enough to be Trump's ego oh I can really
use this it's Paul Manafort and a guy
named gates
oh wait what's this other thing george
papadapolis 30 of Chicago pleaded guilty
on October 5 having made material false
statements and material omissions during
an interview with the FBI case was
unsealed today gee thanks look I know
manna fort it may feel a little like
that Christmas that you expected a bike
but the first two gifts the folks wanted
you to open consisted of a sweater and a
book and wait what was that about George
papadopolis George papadopolis 30 of
Chicago Illinois pleaded guilty on
October 5 2017 to making false
statements to FBI agents in violation of
18 USC 1001 the case was unsealed today
and a sentencing hearing will be
scheduled at a later date I'll get to
Manta Forge I'll get to what is actually
a strategic masterpiece by Muller but
George papadopolis
he pleaded guilty 25 days ago and we are
only hearing about this now he cut a
deal he's been working with Mulder's
investigation for nearly a month George
papadopolis is the small fish with the
big name the trump foreign policy
advisor who according to the plea deal
as long ago as March 2016 was suggesting
cajoling urging needling and emailing
everybody he could think of in the
campaign that Trump was being invited to
meet with and should meet with Vladimir
Putin the plea deal goes on stating that
by April 2016 Papadopoulos emailed Trump
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski about
quote Putin wanting to host Trump and
the team when the time is right from his
plea deal just unsealed Papadopoulos had
quote interactions with an overseas
professor who defended Papadopoulos
understand
to have substantial connections to
Russian government officials the
professor you say Oh what if there's a
professor is there also a Maryann or a
ginger oh wait there actually is a
Maryann or a ginger honor about March
24th 2016 defended Papadopoulos met with
the professor in London
the professor brought with him a female
Russian national the quote female
Russian national introduced to defended
Papadopoulos as a relative of Russian
President Vladimir Putin with
connections to senior Russian government
officials yeah but this still is about
Trump and Putin this isn't about Trump
and Putin and Hillary Clinton
oh no wait actually it is about Trump
and Putin and Hillary Clinton on or
about April 26 2016 defendant
Papadopoulos met the professor for
breakfast at a London hotel during this
meeting the professor told defended
Papadopoulos that he had just returned
from a trip to Moscow where he had met
with high-level Russian government
officials the professor told defended
Papadopoulos that on that trip he the
professor learned that the Russians had
obtained quote dirt on then candidate
Clinton the professor told defendant
Papadopoulos as defended Papadopoulos
later described to the FBI that quote
they the Russians have dirt on her quote
the Russians had emails of Clinton quote
they have thousands of emails this is
some six weeks before Trump jr. and
Kushner and Manafort met with the
Russian lawyer vessel nets kya about
dirt on Clinton it's three months before
Trump said Russia if you're listening I
hope you're able to find the thirty
thousand emails that are missing and
Papadopoulos is singing about this like
a bird about the professor and Mary Ann
and or ginger and then of course there
is still man afford Paul Manafort the
man whose biggest connection to Trump is
the campaign who reportedly went to a
mutual friend and told him I really need
to get to trump and the friend got him
to Trump and somehow he became manager
and then chairman of the campaign and
two months later he's sitting in the
in Trump Tower listening along as the
Russian lawyer who promised to deliver
Russian dirt on Hillary Clinton Reid's
Kremlin talking points to Trump jr. and
Kushner and weeks after that he's
reported to be offering campaign updates
to a Russian oligarch linked to Putin
and a week after that Trump is
apparently about to pick Chris Christie
as his vice president and manna fort
lies to Trump and tells him Trump's
plane has engine troubles and while he's
stuck there he should meet with this
other possible VP and the next thing you
know Mike Pence is Trump's running mate
and days after that Manta Ford is the
head of Trump's campaign as Trump's
campaign is completely changing the
Republican party platform from favoring
the independent rebellion in Ukraine and
getting the Ukrainians missiles to fight
back - instead tacitly supporting the
Russians taking over Ukraine and now
that guy is under indictment for
laundering money for Ukraine and it's
pro-russian leaders and politicians 18
million dollars of it allegedly himself
nine hundred thirty four thousand
dollars just through one rug dealer in
Virginia the only man outside the Trump
family to attend the vessel Matt sky a
meeting that is the wellspring for
possible charges of obstruction of
justice against Trump is now under
indictment for conspiracy against the
United States of America the man who
suddenly replaced Corey Lewandowski as
the unsalaried boss of the Trump
presidential campaign
not long after Lewandowski dismissed
that idea that Trump should meet with
Putin the idea this one kid kept pushing
and pushing and pushing and what was his
name again alright George papadopolis
cooperating witness living in Muller's
cage since the 5th of October but
where's this mower strategic masterpiece
well obviously the Pappa Doppel is part
but maybe just as importantly Trump is
not going to stick his neck out for
George papadopolis nor for Paul Manafort
he's not gonna fire Muller for
Papadopoulos or mana Ford he's not going
to overrule his lawyers who said as late
as Sunday afternoon that the White House
is still cooperating with Muller for the
sake of Papadopoulos or mana Ford he
doesn't get it
Trump and the trumpets are not only
already out there disparaging man afford
and minimizing his role with the
campaign but they started disparaging
him in March Sean Spicer got up at the
White House press podium about Russia
and said quote there is a fine line
between people who want to be part of
something that they never had an
official role in and people who actually
played a role in either the campaign or
the transition and there's been this
discussion of Paul Manafort who played a
very limited role for a very limited
amount of time Muller has hit a huge
target and a smaller possibly more
valuable target and in the indictments
the name Trump isn't mentioned once
Trump can do nothing about this
strategic masterpiece Justice Department
policy states clearly that you only
filed charges if there is a reasonable
likelihood of a conviction at a trial
yes you might indict in an effort to
force somebody to flip looking at you
manna for it but the baseline is this if
you indict them you had better be able
to get a jury to convict them and in
what historians will likely view as the
greatest crime in American history
Bob Muller has already bagged a trump
campaign figure who talked Clinton
emails with the Russians and tried to
arrange for Trump to meet Putin and he's
also indicted Paul Manafort on a charge
of conspiracy against the United States
of America
Owen there was one other tiny little
gift that might be bigger than manna
Ford and gates and maybe even bigger
than Papadopoulos and the professor and
Mary Ann or ginger page 23 of the
indictment statutory allegations the
first count number 38 the defendants
Paul J mana for jr. and Richard Gates
the third together with others knowingly
and intentionally conspired to defraud
the United States by etc.etc
mana Ford and gates together with others
trick or treat
Halloween thus becomes the kind of event
Winston Churchill once described as not
the end
it is not even the beginning of the end
but it is perhaps the end of the
beginning
in fact Bob Mahler has given us a second
present the clear confirmation that this
lovely sweater and the wonderful book
and the other box they are not going to
be the only gifts moer gets us this year
of course this present is marked do not
open until Christmas resist remove these
you could fill the time buying and
reading my book based on these
commentaries it's not a Red Rider BB gun
but it's actually pretty good available
with or without gift wrapping